One
time on my income the sellers asked me as to stay on that and the man
said morass they said it can be say it. But said the same to half
down a half down the road our lady furnished and said if you can go down and down
I guess they will give it to you.
And said he said Grandma rascality nervous that if you let her stay appears
said I'll go down there and stay on
that. He said
he went around them and got immature and said and went to raid in a Bible and said he
heard them coming down out of the Lao
flag chains and said when he looked it was a Mayan thin run
to anything that of a few
will look in on that hearth there he said there's a lot of money
there he said they kill me to get my money but they didn't get it and he said they buried
me out here in the woods he said not at that I think you dig Dan you find
my bones.
And he said there are
that eighty left did derogate it wouldn't
hardly raised said Our want the route this raised up this birdie and I laid our lead money.
And said that he he said to them my and when the HE IS thousand doing
me said there.
In the name of the Father and the Son and the Holy Ghost What do you won't and said
he he told him that and he said if you will take this to coerce you have this half an hour
less
money and said I'd be out in court that hour come and without a
limit what you tell him
so and said he told it in a I'll find it in the court hare
and the man got the half in money
and thought of
me.
My uncle was a doctor one time many had to go. Lots of times I don't not
doctor paper line on the locust ridge my aunt and they have time they start down that my aunt
and he'd a woman had run after the War I
and. And said he could see the moans in your hand there were
bones in her fingers and he said to death. Hey
yeah he shot at her one that said she jumped on the
house and read down the mountain with him and jump out and disappear and he would know where she'd went to.
They're gone D'Amico came a gun up on the mountain waving when he went to Korea and said he shot at
her and they never could hear
her and said he told the people as they were on the Dr they dissed have to
call him and they time are not calling a matter not for he want to go into beyond that mountain I'm a
waiter
not for your brain.
Mind That's why
Martin hour there I can
screw on one of them the man run the
horse there on the road and has no man come the girl. The man
she shot that man shouted hater.
I said that to say that ma'am but not around that horse's head shadow.
That's so thing you know.
Sixth grade.
My
mother said If you ever bothered Bowery Truthout or which is a Mason Rand you describe go a
little south across the lower lay the broom than that if you see the broom layin to go out the door.
If you could a story in but she wouldn't tell me and over that room.
The
whole.